hello everybody my name is keisha Cashin
work in plat 49 today I'm going to talk
about chrome and Chrome devtools and it
will be polite presentations so I'll try
to do things like this is an overview
things we're going to cover today and i
would like to start with workspaces I do
have some swimming functionality layers
so if you guys cannot see you but you
know smaller pore spaces workspaces
allow us to map our project files with
files on local content they're really
easy to set up and do it right now so we
go to sources in devtools we're at click
anywhere and it add folder to work space
navigator
the second step would be to map one of
the existing files 2100 just big and
Neptune file system resource what I do
is they have those who get you started
and great to go the obtuse is smart
enough to find location of other files
relative to the file I just met and hope
it worked out so now i'm going to change
the color of the header thread and now
when i refresh representation it will
get seitan a hundred so this is written
to my file you can do it not only with
CSS for example I have a I have a sass
file under Margaret underground so it's
about to compile or change and now if I
click comment pick on the color if you
bring it the executive place where the
variable is declared and now i can
change it to you
my bus a suit we've compiled and updated
comment but everything you have
livelihood or this is chrome compiling
this is from so I know your stuff which
higher I just have some stuff in the gym
I just through being jealous tells us
because I'm sort of stats in your path
is that knows I assure i Jes instilled
sets compiler and I coach anything the
background oh so I gave it some things
active file and Toyland so chrome edits
the SAS with your background washer
turns out it just gets out all right and
they promoted your CSS change every
loads doesn't it cool sorry it's just so
unstable or something airy and this is
unstable it's been there for like coffee
tonight I subscribe to do is talk it was
like very new things by the way talking
about kiss fellers there is a game
called watercolor by the bureau so
basically suggests that So Cal escape I
bet I can guess color like one minute or
something and it's not just assess we
can reach them as well so this is the
next day so here I can say hello in your
personal life and then here is so it's
an HTML file is saved on hundred the
same thing with JavaScript I'll do a
little trick here there is a button
called pause its execution I think it
and whatever I do with JavaScript now it
will stop there so I looking deep in
this life so it's doc gonna click
handler and here i said alert Oh once I
saved chrome ray compiles dysfunction
and rancid so who is here and every time
I preview it around
so this is oh cool but a lot of times
people use their tools just to try some
things I mean I want to end fighting
here unchain the color and I want to say
this so there are two things which can
be done here first one every time you
change something let me make you can do
comedy and you just under it which is
simple have a second cool thing is there
is local history local notifications
history and accuses gives us thieves or
positive don't get too excited by you so
now that dress up by revision content
yeah I didn't change anything but you
can do it you scroll down down let me
move this other trophies so now how did
I get to this file once you have this
file saving it's pretty much an ID and
I'm going to navigate across our code so
there are certain shortcuts we can use
there is why this search for filing so
they keep goin told I can search for any
file that mr. four underscore have been
nice light now when I found underscored
I can search for all the function has
functions has inside quick use
oh so I can search for for each another
thing there is is it black fog actually
in devtools one more part so here it has
that low Simon there is map and collect
devtools only see the second one any
vestige from web it won't find it and
it's been like beautiful Oh kaffir
another cool feature is searching for
files I was working in deep I was
working with it leaves at some point and
the search there was really slow so this
thing digits saved my life before times
and its control shift F okay so there is
a search panel here and let me search
for both headers of second level here
there it also allows to use regular
expression so if i search for h and some
digits it will find hitters of all
levels one of my personal personal
favorite features is being able to
navigate a cross folded cursor position
in devtools so kind of common function
plus or minus it will take me through
all the places where evening
next yes this is joke related think my
main purchased oh I can see could be
there next thing I'd like to talk about
our snippets basically snippets are
pieces of code you can reuse across
different websites in your problem and
they're pretty cool when you're
debugging something and you want to run
something which is more than my life
console is not that comfortable there
and this is very confusing it is it's
also can be used if you want to try some
quick instead of just the energy spin
heel and let's see how we can use it so
a simple example here I mentioned we
want to debug some somerset and we want
to try to do sonic with jquery let's go
basic interpreter so here there is no
Jake way
yeah so Joe crying sweet side which are
not bad maybe seven post so if i go to
sources sneakers i have a check various
native here and when i write it I have
jquery nikon salsa and now i can do
things like hide wedding show neck or
you could commence
well they're like any standard and you
can do the same as underscore their
couple other sweet snippets file name is
council safe so now I just run it and if
i go to console i can say call so to say
and whatever Jason's cave on say a plus
one so it created a file and it put the
darshan right there so it's really great
if you want to debug and set something
to a friend so basically you go to
sources panel and there is Nikki section
and here are all the sneakers i use so
one of them you just have to click on it
and you have to run here so now i have
got some safe and like Cosmo and there
are more like a race is needed which
convertible images too lazy or else
there is a bit which gives you all
colors on the webpage and I put things
and so my size a book or a poet i will
give you a link in twitter twitter so
there are there are two collections of
sleep is one by foe irish and one by
brian grinstead solar council ready
and some of them are doing pretty cool
things and so now let's talk about
settings first place very problem to go
is from flags here the most interesting
thing here is def those experiments the
most amusing for lista the other is
another finishing step there you can
enable experimental es6 features it's
probably let me quantity here and once
we enabled our experiments in digital
settings we can go to experiments tab
and there are all the cool new features
which will be able and stable version
without this plugin maybe like a puppy
here and its really nice to play with it
and I in January recommended to just go
into settings and see what games they're
like keep adding new interesting things
another good great tablet shortcuts and
let me show you couple more interesting
ones
so when we're in an element Stanhope and
we have any node selected we can just
totally cheesy bits using age it's a
simple the cool thing about it well it
basically does it adds some glass thing
here so what we can do
we can assign some
and now let's make it the ground so now
when i hit age it will talk about
background instead of hiding it which
can be really cool for debugging other
thing and inspecting notes probably all
the people use it whether basically if
you click this icon or use cone ships a
shortcut it allows you to inspect
elements and the whole feature here it
shows you exactly mentions of elements
the tag name last name if any in Tulsa
shows margins which are orange here and
padding's which are cleaning and its
really grateful debugging reality money
when you give an example around one of
the silicates so here imagine i'm
debugging salmon and i want to see what
will be the results of this thing I just
said it and I feel horrible [ __ ] II and
the result will be in a console if I
want to watch something so so here I
hope with h2 innerhtml basically in this
snippet all we doing with iterating over
all the headers in our document and if I
want to watch it I just keep control
ship a and adds it to watch expressions
so now when I continue every time I get
a great point i'll get in you but if you
and if you feel like you're get stuck in
debugging something and you want to skip
all the great points there is this need
to batten which keeps all breakpoints
for half a second
another nice option is having multiple
users in chrome and other people use it
but some people just don't know about it
to edit just go to settings and add new
user
yes and now I get to users here and why
do want to have separate viewers because
every user has all different
configurations all different plugins
different cookies different browser is
everything so if I want to paste some
website with three different users it's
probably something I want to use another
option would be to use yes I got the
same and it was useful not just for
developing like if I have personal gmail
and for gmail that's Anika there is also
incognito mode basically no plugins now
publish nothing it's also great to
destiny if you need different puters dev
tools are written in javascript HTML CSS
and it's really easy to extend them and
at some point somebody figure out oh
well it's just CSS I can change the
custom themes and they cannot be nervous
yeah they come up with all possible
Vince Tigerettes are things there are
things for anybody and later give those
people noches death and I said oh now we
have an API so now they're up install
the plugins in from App Store which are
two things but they're not much of an
there yet there are multiple cool
extensions for dev tools I'm not going
to show anyone just to save some time
but there is called the script console
there is yes 630 there is a terminal
where you can use like your operation
system kernel in devtools if you want to
some real fast it's pretty cool there
are Grantham golf console which
basically allow you to run cow for grass
and Iran tasks in your dev tools there
is the chest in contention there aught
of specific for frame extensions exam
for endured and burn I go can I promise
also extensible everybody knows please
there is a top if you wanna test IE
their essentials like life reload pixel
perfect and different color Pickers
measurements and I compiled a set of
things if you guys want to stay up to
date there is a website called from
status chromium status right here
it shows which version of chrome gets
wish functionality and you can see what
is in development what is just proposed
what's coming next and canary there are
links for three people pull Irish ideas
money for developers of victims and this
mark Hanson who is head of tutorials and
keeps on new functionality a lot more
links under looking slides and let's
pretty much eat my name is a altercation
and I have this week until I was said I
couldn't use it today so I think we have
more time and i'd like to share just
three completely related to climb and
different things but i think they're
pretty cool so first one came with new
firefox nightly now they have eye
dropper so basically i need any plugins
you can infer from steph toes you can
just go and find the color of any
element on the stream second cool cool
thing is audio break bones it's not a
real thing here it's experiment somebody
do that with firefox as you can see here
you can put conditional breakpoint
playing note when something happens it's
big cooler as video there's a i can wait
until somebody with musical talents will
discover that the last thing is remote
debug initiative so basically we have
different browsers and every browser has
it shown by your tools and every my
girls have their own protocol and there
is a guy who's saying like Kenneth house
and everything like it's not cool why
don't we use the same product of
everybody and you created a breach so
here you can see how is debugging
firefox in chrome devtools huh
and for other people are not entirely
happy with this idea and that's it and
this is me thinking so the hockey a tab
our correctly you have to be our pc with
ideas yes you gotta do something first
example with the access did you have the
lively little extension
it's built into chrome by the head
Susskind compiler writings in the
screens for every keystroke see when you
have that see the red lady wide and a
perky stroke in devtools glittery
processor let's go
admissions
you